natalia has worked at this bread factory
in the town of bahrmut in eastern
ukraine for 13 years
russian forces are slowly getting closer
they are first firing artillery shells
and rockets then moving in on nearby
villages
the closer they get the more tempted the
mother of two is to leave
i'm very worried for myself for my
family for the children for my job it's
frightening going to and from work
because i hear the explosions in the
distance i love my job and have many
friends i don't want to leave them
the bread factory is the largest and
oldest business in town employing around
200 people
they supply bread to many surrounding
villages but the amount of customers is
shrinking as they flee the slow russian
army advance
volunteer delivery driver andre
is a brave man
after loading up his van with freshly
baked gloves he heads out of town
towards the front line
we follow him along isolated empty
country roads to a village near the
russian army controlled town of kolivka
the village shopkeeper and few people
still living here have been waiting for
his delivery for three days
over there closer to taurus the whole
field has been shelled so heavily it
looks like they're digging it go have a
look but it's so loud there and there's
still people living there
i don't feel particularly afraid people
need bread they have to eat if they
shell me so be it this is war
the village sits in between the
advancing russian army and ukrainian
military defense dug in across the
fields
the trains stopped coming here in 2014
when pro-russian separatists seized
control of the next city down the tracks
it's terrifying there are explosions
constantly getting food to us is
dangerous and there's never enough we
feel surrounded because they shoot from
this side and that side all of those who
are left here are old there are no
medicines available no buses no
transport here
we drive to touretsk swerving between
piles of soil heaped on the road to try
and slow down any russian army advance
in a nearby village we find homes
destroyed
the ukrainian army tell us that this
village has been hit by russian
artillery a number of times in the last
week they say at least one civilian
has been killed in these strikes the
most recent strike was this morning a
number of civilians injured the soldiers
here tell us that the russian positions
are around seven kilometers from here
ukrainian soldiers say russian forces
are trying to destroy a radio antenna
but so far have only succeeded in
destroying lives
charles stratford al jazeera eastern
ukraine